in November students had a historically
black university in new orleans that a
massive protest against the speaker
heavily supportive of Donald Trump
socially engaged Dillard University
students the group organizing against
the speaker wrote an open letter they
said quote his presence on our campus is
not welcome and overtly subject the
entire student body to safety risks and
social ridicule this is simply
outrageous the speaker safety was
guaranteed by the University and he
proceeded to explain quote I will be
Donald Trump's most loyal advocate the
protesters were of the political left
they chanted no KKK no fascist USA
protesters were hit with pepper spray
and two of them were arrested so here is
the question for you did this make
inviting the speaker worthwhile the
answer should be obvious from st counts
of events you don't have enough
information to say the speaker could
have been Sheriff David Clarke or Rudy
Giuliani or Newt Gingrich or Maya
Annapolis it wasn't it was David Duke
who also said at the same event quote
there is a problem in America with a
very strong powerful tribal group that
dominates our media and dominates our
international banking I'm not opposed to
all Jews if you do not answer that story
provided too little information for you
to judge it's time for you to check your
biases did you decide the speaker was on
the right because the protesters were on
the left did you decide to speaker head
something valuable to say if he ticked
off the left enough if he melted enough
snowflakes unfortunately many
conservatives have embraced this sort of
binary thinking if it pisses off the
left it must be virtuous undoubtedly
that is a crude shorthand for political
thinking it means you never have to
check the ideas of the speaker you
merely have to check how people respond
to him which is dangerous it leads to
people supporting bad policies and bad
men the enemy of your enemy isn't always
your friend sometimes he's your enemy
sometimes you just a dude sitting there
minding his own business you don't have
enough information to know the logic of
if you melt snow flakes use one of us
actually hands power to the left by
allowing leftist to define our friend it
gets to choose whom we support this
isn't speculative it actually happened
during the 2016 primaries when the media
attacked Donald Trump incessantly
driving Republicans into his
outstretched arms the media is obvious
hatred for Trump was one of the chief
arguments for Trump from his advocates
they said if as his detractors claimed
he wasn't conservative why would the
leftist media hate him so much now to be
fair after mitt romney was bludgeoned at
the hands of the media there was at
least a shred of justification for this
logic romney wasn't too hardcore
conservative he wasn't the personal
shambles he got savaged by the media
anyway
for the sin of having an R after his
name the same thing happened to John
McCain a maverick Republican the leftist
media had openly praised for years if
the media opposed Trump with all their
heart and all their soul that must have
been some sort of reaction to Trump
himself it wasn't really though it was a
combination of factors including the
fact Trump was amazing press and the
Prescott Trump was really weak more
honest leftist commentators openly
preferred Trump to more conservative
candidates like Ted Cruz or Marco Rubio
but from swore with the media carried
him to the nomination and from there to
the presidency in fact Trump continues
to live off of this backward logic his
press conference last week it wasn't a
ballet of informational expertise and
policy knowledge nor was it a brilliant
recasting of his policy successes it was
a blunderbuss attack on the media and it
was extremely entertaining it was
occasionally Daft is occasionally
ridiculous but a lot of people on the
right immediately concluded it was the
most successful press conference in the
history of the world not because it was
actually successful with Americans there
was not a lot of evidence of that but
because it was successfully assaulting
the media who had it coming nevermind
Trump lied to the media the media were
angry which meant it worked watching
chuck todd fulminate and chris wallace
rage and down l'amanda musically tut tut
it scratched conservatives where they
itch and it made Trump a hero none of
which is to argue that Trump is lefty or
that conservatives are wrong support a
lot of its policies will talk about his
policies in a second but if your
standard of right and wrong is whether
the left hates it you're making a
category error it is not good enough to
just be opposed by the left you actually
have to oppose the left we must ask what
someone is fighting again not merely
whom we must ask what tools they're
using and we must insist they use the
truth ideas and values matter more than
identity but not anymore the website
density politics focuses on race and
ethnicity and sexual identity aspects of
identity that place you somewhere in the
hierarchy of intersectionality the
rights identity politics comes with a
label enemy of the web so long as you're
wearing that button you're presumptively
on our side and you're nearly
bulletproof until it turns out they are
not until we jump the wrong way because
we substituted political laziness for a
philosophy until we embrace somebody
nasty room because the other side hated
him or her and stopped caring about the
truth so long as the other side is
triggered then we become the bad guys
and that's a big problem i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
okay so I want to talk a lot more about
sort of this enemy of my enemy is my
friend routine that we're getting from a
lot of folks on the right why that isn't
true and how we can actually identify
enemies in a second we're often talked
about Donald Trump's policy she's rolled
out a bunch of policy that's actually
pretty good and I want to talk about a
lot of the policy that he's been rolling
out but first we have to say thank you
to our sponsors over at legacy box so
I've been saying for a long time than
one of the most important things that
you can do in your life is preserve your
memories because over time you lose
memories over time the memories
dissipate people die people move away
and what legacy box does it make sure
that you can preserve all those old
memories so you've got a big box of
moldering film in your bay in your
basement or in your in your attic in
your garage instead of it just sitting
there you take all that stuff you pack
it up you ship it off the legacy box and
they immediately transfer it they
reconstructed they transfer it into a
DVD they put on a thumb drive for you to
now it's all accessible it's a simple
affordable way to get your recorded
moments digitally preserved on DVD or
thumb drive twenty two hundred fifty
thousand families have used them
including my own parents for limited
time go to legacy box calm slash
spending at forty percent off your order
which is a pretty major discount forty
percent off your order when go to legacy
box calm / been use the / vents they
know that we sent you and again I think
that this is about the best use of your
money that there is because you know
once those memories are gone they're
gone and if something happens if your
basement floods there's a fire you don't
want to be in a position where you lose
all those memories just because they
were all packed in a box somewhere in
the back of the garage and you forgot
about it much better to have them handy
on your computer on a thumb drive on a
DVD that's what legacy box does legacy
box calm / Ben and they take really good
care of stuff like they mark it with a
bar codes that you know where every
piece of the inventory is at all times
they updated online to tell you the
progress terrific terrific service
legacy box calm / been okay so I want to
talk a little bit about Donald Trump's
policy so this is fun we actually let's
do a good Trump bad form because
actually get to do some good Trump today
which is exciting it's a good drum pad
room
[Music]
we'll begin and as always thanks to our
composer Brandon tonight's here is
Donald Trump good Trumpy hey there it is
good from so that whole Mike Flynn
debacle with the National Security
Advisor that ended up actually working
out pretty well for the country because
Mike Flynn is out and the guy who
replaced him is going to HR McMaster now
HR McMaster is a lieutenant general and
he is terrific I've read his book
dereliction of duty i read it must have
been now seven eight years ago because
there was a point when the i think the
army of the war college they posted
online their recommended reading list i
read everything on the recommended
reading list and one of those books was
a charming masters book on the vietnam
war called dereliction of duty about the
strategy that came out of the JFK and
LBJ administration's with regard to the
Vietnam War widen strategy was flawed
and why the military should have stood
up against the strategy instead of
simply implementing a really crappy
strategy a strategy called graduated
escalation which was the idea that we
would gradually increase the number of
troops in Vietnam we'd squeeze the Viet
Cong and then they would surrender as
opposed to the way the wars are actually
one which is overwhelming force there's
a lot thing you should know about HR
McMaster first of all the guy has an
awesome superhero name second of all his
army resume is really really extensive
his previous command assignments
included the Eagle troop 2nd Armored
Cavalry Regiment in Germany and then
Southwest Asia during the first Gulf War
he was the commander he was commander
during Afghanistan as commander during a
rock he wrote dereliction of duty which
as I say it's a really good book you
should go to amazon right now and pick
it up it's really a first-rate read he's
a great writer and he's a really good
thinker he was both he was critical of
both how Afghanistan and Iraq war plan
so what he wrote in survival magazine he
wrote gaps between prior visions of
future warfare and the nature of the
eventual Wars themselves complicated
efforts to adapt strategy over time
minimalist linear plans in place at the
outset of both wars were disconnected
from the ambition of broader policy
objectives and the complexity of the
operating environment indeed recent war
plans have at times been essentially
narcissistic failing to account for
interactions with determined enemies
another complicating variable choose
writing this in real time he was saying
in real time our strategy is not going
to meet your objectives if you want a
long-term occupation thinking to work he
used his own strategy in a place called
Tal Afar and rock and George W Bush
called it a model of a successful
strategy he figured that a rock could
not
its own institutions political or
military until safety was secured so he
devised his own plan in which he and his
troops cleared the towns of insurgents
and formed alliances build trust with
local shakes and tribal leaders and the
campaign works as a while but only
because McMaster flooded the area right
he actually did what he had suggested in
dereliction of duty he flooded the area
and that was what they called the queer
hold build strategy Petraeus used
McMaster as sort of his brain in
devising his strategy with regard to
Iraq he was not selected for Brigadier
General promotion before he finally
received it in 2014 one of the reasons
for that is because they're a bunch of
retired generals who said that he was he
was up ending the system too much they
didn't want to reward him he is warned
about cuts to the arm he's a really
really good nominees about the best guy
you could have in this particular slot
and he is also ensured he says that he
would not come in he said that he would
not he would not join basically unless
he were guaranteed the until until
unless he was guaranteed the ticking of
his own staff so this is actually a big
issue as when left was Trump wanted to
maintain Flynn staff and mcmaster came
in and said listen you want me you're
going to have to let me take my own guys
which is great you want people like
McMaster surrounding himself with really
good people and giving Donald Trump
really good advice so whether Trump
takes that advice we'll find out but
good for Donald Trump for picking
McMaster really really good pick there
other things that are good to Donald
Trump is doing so he's getting a lot of
flak today because the White House has
now stepped away from the trans bender
transgender bathroom nonsense that
Barack Obama foisted on the nation when
he suggested the federal government is
going to cram down on local schools all
around the country the idea that people
could go to the bathroom basically of
their choice course which or with which
that accommodated the sex with which
they identify another actual biological
sex Trump has stepped away from that as
well he should however you stand on the
transgender bathroom debate which is
really a silly debate in my opinion
however you stand on it this should be a
local control issue there should not be
a federal issue the ideas the federal
government stepped in there in the first
place is idiotic and good for Trump for
stepping away from it apparently about
you too boss the secretary Secretary of
Education wanted to maintain that that
policy and and the Attorney General jeff
Sessions did not and from side of the
sessions right call from Donald Trump
other good things that are happening
under Trump Scott Pruitt who's the new
head of the Environmental Protection
Agency
he gave a speech at the EPA in which he
basically told the regulators look guys
your job is not to punish businesses
your job is to create a stable set of
regulations that are predictable so that
people can operate within the bounds of
those regulations which is exactly right
here's Scott Pruett who is hotly
contested talking to all of his
employees the EPA regulations ought to
make things regular regulators exist to
give certainty to those that they
regulate those that we regulate ought to
know it's expected to them so that they
can plan and allocate resources to
comply that's really the job of a
regulator that in the process that we
engage in in adopting regulations is
very very important because it sends a
message it sends a message that we take
seriously our role of taking comment in
an offering response and then making
informed decisions on how it's going to
impact those in the marketplace self-ins
very vague what he's actually saying is
that what regulators very often do is
they make their own priorities v
priority they don't care about creating
a stable business environments that
people know what the rules are and
they're constantly throwing monkey
wrenches into the works so good for
Scott Pruett Scott for it's a very good
pic at EPA I think he's really going to
reform things over there where things
are a little bit more vague remains on
the deportation policy what that's
actually going to look like so i wanted
to talk about an email that i received
yesterday which i thought was really an
interesting and good email that is
worthy of thought and discussion so i
got an email yesterday from a from a
person who suggested that who suggested
that yesterday when I said you know when
we're over rating you know the level of
change here everybody needs to calm down
a little bit everybody needs to stop
worrying quite so much because not that
much has happened yet you know why is
everybody really going crazy and this
this immigration lawyer wrote to me who
listens to the program and he said well
you know I think that's a little bit
overstated like there are people whose
lives have actually changed there are
people whose lives have actually changed
and he said particularly in immigration
sphere so he's an immigration lawyer and
what he said is that he is that it what
I and find the exact email now what he
basically said was that there's a lot of
vagueness as far as how the immigration
plans are being implemented and that's a
problem that's a problem because the
because if you're an immigrant journal
legal immigrant you don't know what to
expect tomorrow you don't know whether
you're being deported where they're not
being deported the Obama mended Trump
administration has been really big on
this so they've issued an executive
order that basically does say that you
don't have to have committed a crime
beyond being an illegal immigrant in
order to be deported but then they've
also said that they're not going to be
in favor of mass deportations but then
they've also arrested people who have
come in to to report their their
immigration compliance to check in with
the court and then these people have
been arrested and deported which has
been a problem I think that's a fair
critique I do think that's a fair oak or
take Sean Spicer didn't help when he
added to the confusion a little bit
yesterday here is a here's Sean spice
you're talking about mass deportations
one of the goals here of mass
deportation no this is what I think what
we have to get back to is understanding
a couple things there's a law in place
that says you know if you're in this
country illegally that we have an
obligation to make sure that the people
who are in this mate in our country are
here legally what the order sets out
today is ensures that the million or so
people that have been adjudicated
already that there's a that ice
prioritizes creates a system of
prioritization and make sure that we
walk through that system in a way that
protects this country this is consistent
with everything the president has talked
about which is prioritizing the people
who are here representing a threat to
public safety or have a criminal record
and all this does is lay out the exact
procedures to make sure that that
subgroup of people who pose a threat to
our nation because of a conviction or a
violation public safety or have a
criminal record are adjudicated first
and foremost that's it plain and simple
okay so that's it so that's fine except
for the fact that the executive orders i
was a little bit more than that's what
you're getting from the trump
administration is where none kind of
mass support we're not knocking down
doors and then what you're getting in
terms of the actual policy that's
written out that they have the capacity
to do that a little bit of clarity would
be good i think that it would be good
for for Ann Coulter's heart rate if she
could get a little clarity on what this
policy actually looks like because it's
still a little the day we don't know
what it looks like so when I say don't
panic yet I'm not saying that we
shouldn't keep an eye on it I'm saying
that we need better definition before we
panic that we need a little bit of the
better definition before we panic on any
of that and before we go any further we
have to say thank you to another one of
our great sponsors blue aprons so if
you're somebody who loves a home-cooked
meal but you don't actually know how to
cook you don't know what you're doing
you don't know what ingredients to get
and every home-cooked meal for you is
macaroni and cheese from a box then you
need to talk with our friends over at
blue apron blue apron is this fantastic
fantastic company where you go to their
their website you subscribe basically
and you can buy meals that are shipped
to you but they trip the ingredients to
you and then you cook it yourself all of
the meals take 40 minutes or less to
prepare it's ten dollars per meal and
we're talking like hi we're talking high
level stuff didn't cashew chicken
stir-fry with tango mandarins and
jasmine rice I'm talking mood on noodle
soup with meat on soft boiled eggs by
even pronounce that correctly we're
talking about for the non-jewish among
us we're talking about roasted pork with
apple walnut and farro salad I mean all
of this stuff sounds fantastic and I
know that and reclaim it is cooked with
blue apron he loves it I know that a lot
of my friends in cook with blue apron
they love it it is very affordable they
provide variety two new recipe pretty
much every day and they do not repeat
recipes over the course of a year so
it's a constant stream of good food and
you never know how much you enjoy food
until you eat the same thing every night
or until you're on a set schedule with
food one of the wonderful things about
blue apron is that they rotate all of
these meals and everything is super
duper fresh again it's for less than ten
dollars per meal per person and they
deliver these seasonal recipes along
with those pre-portioned ingredients to
make delicious home-cooked meals they
send these fresh high-quality
ingredients direct to your house really
really really good stuff and it makes
meal time into kind of a celebration of
family and food and that's a that's what
it should be if you go right now to blue
apron calm / repair you get the first
three meals free with free shipping
which is a pretty awesome deal blue
aprons calm / shapiro you will love how
good it feels now that it tastes to
create these fantastic home-cooked meals
with blue apron check it out right now
blue apron calm / shapiro is a huge
thing in LA like everybody's using blue
apron now and they really should because
it's awesome so blue apron calm /
shapiro to check it out okay so with all
of this side with all the stuff that
Trump is doing a lot of which is really
good now we have to discuss how we
define and how we determine whether
conservatives when conservative should
stick with from from when they shouldn't
stick with Trump and this is not
it's very weird i think that we felt as
i said at the beginning we followed into
this binary thinking with regard to
politicians if the left hates someone
they must be our friend the web states
Trump therefore everything Trump does is
good and that's really silly and at the
same time there a lot of people who
oppose Trump and they feel like if you
oppose from then that must make you good
that must be a good thing as I've said
before I don't think it's important
whether you oppose Trump or support
Trump I don't think Trump is important I
think that his policies are important i
think the things he says are important
because he's president of the united
states and so it's a big mistake to
identify your friends and enemies by
simply defining a friend who you will
always follow no matter what or to
finding an enemy will always go against
no matter what and you'll always assume
they're wrong no matter what that's a
big mistake I want to talk a little bit
more about that but you're going to have
to go over today lee weyer calm to hear
all of that become a subscriber for
eight dollars a month over at daily wire
cama a lot of goodies coming if you
become a subscriber right now that we're
giving away is a is a fictional film
called the arroyo which you can check
out i think we're doing a live stream of
the arroyo actually on friday on
facebook so you can check out the arroyo
there do you have a trailer for it
actually we're supposed to grab a
trailer if not then we'll have the
trailer for tomorrow and we'll play that
on daily water so you can check out what
it is that you're getting if you become
a subscriber its daily wear calm we're
going to play the whole movie on Friday
on our Facebook page so check that out
today lee weyer calm eight bucks a month
for subscribing annual subscription you
get that video plus you get all sorts of
goodies the Shapiro store is supposed to
open I keep saying this but it will open
in the very very near future and there
will be all sorts of new things that are
wonderful including I really want to get
those buttons i had a button that my
speech last night they're they're a
bunch of people who wore stickers that
said UCSB against hate UC santa barbara
against eight so i wore a button that
said me against you sucking so i think
that will make some goods like that
available to you as well because you
should let all your friends know that
you are against them sucking so we will
definitely make that available but check
that out also you can listen later
obviously at itunes or soundcloud we are
the most listened to and most watch
conservative podcast in the nation
you